in today's money watch we're talking
about the slowdown in the housing market
yesterday the Federal Reserve raised
interest rates by another three quarters
of a percentage Point as it continues to
fight inflation this comes as mortgage
rates hit a 20-year high at just over
seven percent in the National
Association of realtor says existing
home sales continue to decline so what
does that mean for you CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger joins us now to
talk about it Jill good morning good
morning so the rate started out at 3.2
percent at the start of the year they're
over seven percent incredibly expensive
how's that impacting the real estate
market well it is really spooking a lot
of would-be buyers but let's just kind
of review these numbers for a second
those numbers sound big but let's make
some context if you were looking at say
a four hundred thousand dollar house at
the beginning of this year you had 20
percent down you did it all your saving
you put that money down you got yourself
a 30-year fixed rate mortgage the
payment for your principal and interest
was about let's say almost fourteen
hundred dollars now just months later
not even a year later that same payment
is over twenty one hundred dollars a
month that's an extra nine grand over
the course of a year and it means that a
lot of people who were looking in the
housing market have to lower their
expectations and that is where we're
seeing a real deceleration in activity
do you have an easy explanation on why
it's so high well I mean look mortgage
rates are high because all interest
rates are actually rising and so that's
part of what we've been seeing all year
since the FED started raising interest
rates but the interesting thing also is
that actually home prices they are
decelerating but they're also slowing
down some but they do remain high why
because we don't have a ton of inventory
and I think that's the real issue like
you have people who are first-time home
buyers who say I don't want to buy but
there's not so much to buy so prices are
still pretty high then and I think that
that's a tough Push Pull yesterday Joe
on this show that it was described in
Nancy's piece as a tug of war between
buyers and sellers do you see it that
way and who's going to win well I think
buyers and sellers are both impacted
let's let's look at it from the buyer
perspective we're talking about how
affordability has really changed so I'm
a buyer I can't afford as much so that
means I'm stuck in the rental market
we'll get to that in a second but that's
tough sellers meanwhile you know you
have a lot of people who would think
about maybe moving up but let's say
you've got that beautiful house and a
three percent mortgage rate yeah now I
don't want to move and so now I'm I
don't have as much inventory so okay now
there's lower inventory it means the
market frenzies dying down the average
price for a median home is dropping it's
not down yet but it is dropping and
we're that frenzy of bidding over the
price of the house the number of days on
the market it was down in the teens for
a number of days now it's at 50 days all
of these things really tell us that the
Home Market is Shifting and there is a
push pull between buyers and sellers
it's Market by market but I still think
that sellers have an advantage you know
the thing if you're selling don't get
stuck in that moment of oh I could have
gotten this much money a year ago deal
with today and if it still makes sense
sell your house you mentioned renters uh
was there something you're going to add
there yes okay so rents we know have
been rising and I've been focusing on
those younger folks you know the 25 to
35 year olds and what we've seen is that
affordability of rent has really hit
that group so much because they're
they're uh annual incomes are not Rising
enough to catch up with rents so the
share of their income to rent is rising
now here's the weird thing when we look
at these markets is that just the fact
that rents are so high are probably a
sign that that will mean that rents will
come down because landlords will not
have the leverage if people are saying
you know what I'm moving back in with
Mom and Dad or I'm going to sleep on
vlad's couch for a while that's going to
help rents come under control that has a
nice couch
nice couch but the guest room is going
to be a yes I will have an extra
occupant in the house starting do you
always hear the things that you can do
to boost the sale of your to boost the
attractiveness of your home little
cosmetic thing okay I want to tell you
that there's a great survey out and it
said like what brings you Joy of like if
you're going to stay in that house so
refinishing hardwood floors and painting
are some of the projects that really
start to bring you Joy closets a lot of
people say doing their closets the
strange thing is a lot of the projects
that you think pay off in the long run
don't so you know everyone's like oh I
want to do my kitchen I want to do my
bathroom actually when you look at those
projects specifically you can't recoup
the amount of money you spend on those
big projects so just be careful I
replace the grout behind my kitchen sink
personally myself the greatest feeling
on Earth greatest feeling wait a second
does anyone else need some grout it
looks amazing well you know who to call
thanks Jill always good to have you here